this month five men in britain were
sentenced to a combined total of 50
years in prison for attempting to
smuggle firearms in from the united
states
only on cbs this morning saturday ian
lee gives us an inside look
at the joint police operation that
tracked those guns from atlanta
to england oh police officers
come to the front door with your hands
where i can see them a transatlantic
police operation
comes to an end on a quiet british
street an
organized criminal gang in the uk
arrested three handguns from the us
seized the weapons put up for sale by
the gang on an encrypted social media
platform
were bought legally in atlanta then
smuggled in bluetooth speakers via miami
to the uk
all the exhibits all packaged up we got
a look at those guns at a secure
undisclosed location in england you've
got two frames
two magazines there's long lead barrel
martin parker is chief scientist for the
uk's national ballistics intelligence
service
his department tests every seized
firearm
including those handguns captured in
this raid that's your weapon
what makes this so attractive i mean
it's it's light it's compact
the capacity and also incredibly
lucrative
in the united states i can walk into a
store and buy one of these guns for a
few hundred dollars
but here in the united kingdom a
criminal will pay up to six
thousand dollars and there's a big
reason
criminals are willing to pay big money
for american guns
says matthew perfect at the national
crime agency
the uk's answer to the fbi the
attraction is having that
blanket clean record to it so your
weapon is coming in generally you know
it's going to be boxed it's going to be
new
a new gun stripped of its serial number
is harder to trace
and the serial numbers are raised
there's a little
serial number we have various techniques
of actually revealing those serial
numbers
authorities traced the guns back to a
store in atlanta
detective chief inspector simon dewfall
led the operation
against the gang you know what we are
seeing is an upward trend of the
of guns coming out of gun stores in
america and you know
the parcel service is being used to
ship them to the uk and obviously into
the criminal hands
despite strict laws against private gun
ownership
uk police are seeing a rise in illegal
firearms
a small but steady stream coming from
the u.s
nearly 900 in the last three years
u.s homeland security saw a significant
increase in firearm seizures destined
for the uk
and so in 2015 an anti-gun smuggling
operation was set up
an official at homeland security
investigations claimed
this american british partnership has
helped prevent
three different terrorist plots it also
stopped british teenager
kyle davies who was obsessed with the
columbine high school killers
from obtaining a u.s handgun for a
planned mass shooting
what does it mean to get these guns off
the street
if they would have ended up in the
criminal hands the consequences would
just be unimaginable
and it'll stay unimaginable if they can
keep the guns
off the streets for cbs this morning
saturday ian lee
london i mean stopping three terrorist
plots pretty impressive
really that's what this can do by
working that's diplomacy working
together
that's how it works and how it should
work